hello everybody my name is markiplier
I'm here with Jack are we same team yeah
yeah if there's a bum bum in front of me
oh my god we get to try together and
against new people oh I did I did
nothing I did a baby that's why I never
rush in as a surgeon everyone thinks
it's like it's like I am a DD so this is
like a whole group of AT&T boom boom
boom boom boom Oh what happened there
oh I hit it I hit it twice you hit a
June good good job good job dear wait oh
[ __ ] I knew though way to go yeah whoo
well I guess when no one else is
actually trying here this there's
opportunity for everybody to succeed I'm
on for I'm going for shits do anything
else anymore with this whole game I just
scored a goal to hit the ball twice I'm
happy you don't need to do any more just
retire you know yeah before something
shameful can happen for all my
hamstrings oh no this one yeah I'm full
that's just like an accident that
happened huh oh [ __ ] I could I could
have done that better I could have done
that better I'm gonna hang back I'm
gonna hang back hang on I almost got it
I'm hanging back hanging back good good
time on us no not far [ __ ] okay I Wow
I shadow ah go back there ball yeah yes
no Jesus no oh [ __ ]
libido Sepideh it's libido clever murder
all that was like just he didn't even
mean to do that he just hit his other
teammate oh man what let's wait the
whole goal explodes funky goal and
everyone gets blasted back alright I'll
hang back I'll hang back hanging back
hanging back ready ready oh you saw
everything presentation for a set E oh
[ __ ] didn't do okay they're not doing
anything
Wow [ __ ] okay brother
oh I was trying backward I was trying
I tried look at me look at me look at me
try let's try and hold yeah I could have
jumped there I didn't try hard enough
I'm the worst I forget you forgive me
the internet won't ever forgive me mate
won't the internet never forgets oh it's
gonna be such like emotionally cold
showers after this
I actually I actually tried to take more
cold showers these days apparently it's
good for you oh yes yeah good goal is
what who did it I was look I was
watching from a distance so my emotional
support was being thrust at you whose
get you're welcome you're welcome
[ __ ] you for me huh [ __ ] you for Beto
good job other teams successful beat oh
[ __ ] you for Beto get rest don't you get
good scrub
come at me scrub Lord I'm ripped yeah
exactly it's my favorite line did Ross
like make that up or is it just like I'm
sure it's on the internet somewhere drop
what is loose to jump it with a club
oh [ __ ] balls and ass oh oh that was
that was just a big pile of no no great
pass ha ha ha
did you know that you can say things
with the directional pad can you oh yeah
they'll actually say it out loud that
was like those like no it types it out
for everybody to see woah oh I wanted to
know Nate no no no no no no nope ok good
good
you've got everything look at this [ __ ]
I was just like Oh ball it's literally
all idea yeah I wish I could hang out
hang back like that that'd be really
cool I have a hat trick now for nothing
wow they scored all three of her yeah oh
this is the best round of rocket League
ever hello people I'm good exactly
ignore everything else remember I beat
you already therefore I'm all
automatically more skilled than you are
so
in fact you know this is a week go we
almost did it again
ah strike back and you steal all the
gold from everybody else I mean that was
my strategy but then I just decided to
let other people do you know Obatala
[ __ ] yeah I destroyed someone I've he's
tried him I blew and he stole him with
destruction yes exactly
he is so welcome for how awesome I am
and good it to be like damn that booper
dooper case so good haha oh I saw that
is everything okay oh nice what you
almost knocked it back out again look at
you in the corner I'm so happy I'm so
happy for you thank you thank I was
happy for you but then you said go [ __ ]
yourself so you know there's only so
much term of endearment to me really is
that just the Irish way oh that's the
Irish man quote holy Lord eighty ow my
anus Irish people can't be happy for
each other
exactly can't show emotion that would be
horrible unless the drink is in yet oh
of course
oh no no get it up do it good job will
love you can other Antony whoa oh crap
I'm on the go
it's okay fine okay we got this so glad
we're recording this episode as well
this is nuts
I'm telling you man real people they're
insane it's like it's one of those
rounds were yeah we're I actually did
well it's like oh I got blown yes yeah
oh yeah yeah you're kicking ass Wow Wow
I fight for everybody yay if I could
patch you in the ass I would yeah holy
you know my thing like you got the high
fives pubes got the brofist can I have
the a spat
can that be my pending yes me oh yes I
would love that
I I'll make it a thing it's official now
everyone know that actually it's
probably not a good idea just talking
about boobs and now you're talking about
a spats yeah people are gonna think that
I've got issues that I need to work at
you oh please go in please going oh oh
too close go back you like football
right yeah I mean it's like ooh oh god
that's not that scary okay
yes like I tolerate it I watch it if at
all and after that knows to do
I don't actively follow it or anything
ah I got your foot tough so get in there
and now you got glitched and some other
guy probably it happens all the time
with me uh-huh i'ma just hang back steal
everybody else's chances yeah exactly we
go here we go this is it you want
yes oh no oh go in the gold it was
almost there stay there
I don't mind here I mean we're up to so
long as anything catastrophic doesn't
happen she have you like in oh no no no
no no no no damn it
bo libido all right I'm gonna play
defensive for the rest of the game I'm
gonna like stick around our goal cuz I
know look at full be dough not skipping
the replay you have to see his own board
what a douche libido you're wearing some
bloopers alright I got gold and boy wow
thanks hey thank you
hey buddy hey how's it go on there you
having a good time here you having a
good time friend paintball colored thank
you it comes the ball I got it
get out of here Paul good job good job
good job good be good you did good
now go score that cool where's your
coming back are you coming back for me
it's 30 seconds remaining
I like those odds uh-huh okay coming
back I almost got it again [ __ ] [ __ ] get
out of here
hey burek scrublord get rekt ball nice
going back to the goal going back to the
goal
well I always score getting it ready do
you know how to do a bicycle kick I do
but it's incredibly [ __ ] hard to pull
off
I did one once it was recorded - hmm Oh
in real life no right yeah I was
recording it with Wade okay yeah Oh
touch the ground and game over Josh
good job fish the game okay I got
flowers for a rocket trip helmet paint
Oh
oh that was cool okay Oh what that was
that was really fun though I love this
game so much it's super good so thank
you everybody so much for watching
thanks Jack for being here no prob maybe
we'll play one more maybe just one more
thanks again everybody as always we'll
see you in the next one hi troll yeah
well I mean we're trying to good at this
oh oh I got to stop talking about boobs
people think I have a problem